Iran banked groups form a land bridge
across the Middle East and connect in an
alliance that tan caus the axis of
resistance its focus to oppose the West
it can both transport equipment and
Personnel but it can also use these
position to attack us interests or
threaten Israel closer to its borders
the alliance has been brought into Focus
amid the Hamas Israel war as the groups
are mobilizing on multiple fronts whoa
at the same time so here's how Iran
built out the network across the Middle
East and what it means for the US and
Israel so to show you where Iran's
so-called access of resistance works in
the Middle East we have Iran over here
and then of course Hamas in Gaza over
here on the on the Mediterranean there's
another group that Iran supports in Gaza
called the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
which is actually a closer Ally of Iran
ideologically but also working out of
Gaza here and also in the West Bank Bank
Iran's most important uh militia Ally is
Hezbollah here in Lebanon aside from
that they also have Syria president
Bashar Al Assad here and various
militant groups in Iraq and then finally
they also have an alliance with the
houthis in Yemen down here down here
south these connections allow Iran to
expand its influence in the Middle East
and make it easier for the country to
transport military equipment personnel
and weapons through the
region one of Iran's AIMS in the Middle
East is to always keep the fight or the
military fight as far away from its own
borders as possible and the presence of
these Military Allies in the landbridge
kind of helps it do that to understand
why Iran has this belt of influence in
the region we need to go back a few
decades following the Iranian Revolution
in 1979 Tran has sought to exert
military cultural and ideological
dominance across the Middle East that
led to the creation of of the kuds force
a branch of the Iranian military which
was later led by kasim
solmani solmani became famous in the
west over the past decade or so because
Iran decided to elevate his profile as
The Mastermind the architect behind this
modern iteration of of the exis of
resistance
later salmani was killed in a drone
strike ordered by the
US salmani was
plotting imminent and Sinister attacks
on American diplomats and military
personnel but we caught him in the
act and terminated him the strike was
aimed at weakening Iran's ability to
threaten American interests in Iraq and
across the
region but that goal hasn't materialized
Iran has continued to supply groups such
as Hamas with weapons and training on
October 7th Hamas designated a terror
organization by the US launched a broad
assault on Israel killing
1,200 Iranian supreme leader Ali H said
immediately after the attack that Iran
did not have a hand in planning it but
supported
it to try and curb Iran's influence the
US works with Allied countries to have a
presence of bases and troops across the
middle
east of course Israel here and Saudi
Arabia here as the two sort of Main and
closest allies against Iranian influence
Jordan has also for very long been a
been a very firm us Ally and the US also
has Partners in the Gulf the US also has
a presence in some of the countries
where it's where it's competing for
influence with Iran for example in Iraq
of course um and the US also still has a
military presence in in Northern Syria
where it's been Allied for many years
with Kurdish forces in the fight against
Islamic State but now also maintains a
military presence to sort of counter
this Iranian land bridge or the threat
from Iran to to us interests and
allies Teran backed groups operating in
this region have been particularly
active since October 7th so let's remove
all of these and take a look at what's
been happening on October 7th Hamas
attacked Israel here on the border with
Gaza Israel responded with a major
military offensive on Gaza but Iran's
allies have also responded to this
Israeli attack from different sides most
importantly the Hezbollah militia in the
northern part with Israel has engaged in
skirmishes with Israeli soldiers Iranian
militias in Syria have also gotten
closer to the Border where they have
engaged in skirmishes down here in Yemen
the Iranian Allied houthi Rebels have
both fired rockets at Southern Israel
but also kep captured a vessel in the
Red Sea the houthis also launched drones
and missiles at other commercial vessels
in the area that led to a us-led
multinational task force stepping in to
try and protect one of the world's most
vital shipping lanes and elsewhere
iranian-backed militias in Iraq and
Syria conducted nearly 100 rocket
attacks against US forces over the past
2 months according to the Pentagon even
though there's been these types of
attacks with increased frequency over
the past decade or so in this context of
course of course they compound pressure
on Israel and help sort of pressure
Israel in this context where they are
where they're fighting Hamas and
Gaza although Iran's axis of resistance
has claimed attacks on multiple fronts
amid the Hamas Israel war Middle East
analysts believe a wider regional
conflict is unlikely for now even though
other parts of this Alliance have
distanced themselves from the October
7th attacks the fact that there was a
big attack on Israel has given the
alliance a bit of momentum but also put
a little bit of pressure to be honest on
some of the other uh militant groups to
to both to strike a bit of Israel and
and to come to the defense of the
Palestinians who are now under severe
air strikes and a ground invasion in
Gaza so far groups in the alliance have
been sticking to calculated and
strategic strikes rather than moves that
could risk a full-blown conflict with
Israel and its
allies